[Musique]
lena chic et créatrice de vêtements depp
cycling elle récupère des vêtements
anciens taché ou inutilisable pour
confectionner des pièces de collection
elle a ainsi créé sa marque le porte
manteau j'ai fait ça parce que pour moi
ça me paraissait logique en fait quand
j'ai commencé à courir d'un coup je le
faisais quand j'étais petit je partais
pas de tissu je perds culture de
vêtements que j'avais déjà sur le
vêtement qui est déjà existants bah faut
s'adapter à ce qu'on a et j'aime bien
aussi ce côté là j'adore les vêtements à
motifs et du coup c'est pour ça que
c'est ce que j'essaye de récré
quand je couds là ça va être des motifs
sur les manches j'ai commencé avec les
réseaux parce que j'avais pas de contact
on que ça fait que les réseaux ça permet
vraiment de se faire des contacts de
voir aussi si ça plaît parce qu'aussi au
départ les gens avant d'acheter ils vont
suivre parce qu' il aime ce que tu fais
au début les na devait travailler dans
une friperie parisienne en parallèle à
cette activité alors secondaire quand
j'ai vu que ça commençait à prendre un
peu et qu'en fait le fait d'avoir de
travailler sur farhi rentrée de devoir
coudre le soir partir le matin et tout
ça prenait trop de temps bah j'ai arrêté
vu que je dors chez ma mère je peux me
le permettre encore même si je gagne pas
mal il vraiment avec pour l'instant
avant j'avais le temps de coudre mais
c'est vrai que du coup je n'avais pas le
temps aussi de faire du bon contenu pour
les réseaux donner envie aux gens
d'acheter et entretenir l'image de
marque grâce au réseau implique
forcément quelques contraintes une
journée normale on va dire se finit vers
18h 18h30 mais en fait c'est à partir de
ce moment là où les gens ils sont sur
leur téléphone sur les réseaux et donc
c'est à personne ce moment là qu'il faut
poster nous pour que l'on puisse être vu
etc je prends la vidéo ce qu'il faut
c'est que j'ajoute une musique il faut
trouver la musique qui va bien qu'il va
aller avec le style la pleurent
ok c'est pas mal on ajoute après faut
trouver la photo qui va être en
couverture
donc c'est la première photo que les
gens vont voir quand ils ont cliqué
dessus en fait on met la petite légende
et voilà et après on publie et c'est bon
j'adore le côté artistique on va dire de
quel genre de photo je vais pouvoir
prendre qu ils soient jolies quel genre
de vidéos qui peuvent être sympa etc
mais après par moments c'est quand même
une contrainte de se dire justement
balla il est 18 heures il faut que je
poste parce que c'est là que les gens
sont dispo à 20h la faudrait que je
mette une story parce que les gens ils
sont sur leur téléphone vers 21h un
stade c'est génial mais c'est horrible à
la fois en fait est que si on poste pas
moi je vois la différence entre quand je
vais poster super longtemps et que je
vais avoir je suis pas 500 vues sur une
story et qu'un jour je post a le
lendemain j'en ai 40 quoi aujourd'hui il
enseigne le porte-manteau ne rapporte
pas assez d'argent à la créatrice pour
en vivre fait dépend des mois quand je
fais les pop up ça marche très bien
parce qu'il ya des gens
d'internet qui viennent plus les
passants parce qu'en fait aussi ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est club cycling s'est pas
non plus donner des gens qui adorent qui
me met des commentaires qui trouve que
ce que je fais c'est trop beau mais
causent pas franchir le pas sur internet
pour le futur et une fois des revenus
réguliers assure elena aimerait bien
franchir une nouvelle étape embauché un
seul a plus qu'un atelier c'est vraiment
ce qui me manque c'est plus être avec
quelqu'un réfléchir à deux pas forcément
sur la création mais tous cas pas
justement
quelqu'un qui est qui et on va poster
quand qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour ça
et cetera
cela lui permettrait de déléguer
certaines tâches administratives voire
même sur les réseaux et se consacrer
pleinement à sa véritable passion nope
cycling j'espère que ça vous plaira et
on se retrouve bientôt pour la première
collection
[Musique]